[Music]
how are you kids hmm
amazing grown it's shocking they're both
in college can you believe that
and mark
it's over
oh
oh i'm sorry to hear that
it's okay
i'm back to me
and my work you know it's
that's great it's good it is i'm alone
at last exciting times
yeah i'm living the alan grant life it's
just gonna be lonely so free
ally
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am going to get her back
power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
foreign
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what is that because carnivore the world
has ever seen
see not so bad
[Music]
[Music]
you